[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
for this week anyway Mark Ellis I am
joined by my esteemed co-host uh as
always the delightful the um the very
the choosy but she's making the right
decisions when it comes to the things
that we talk about off camera which
range from Sports to attraction we talk
about a lot of stuff here in the studio
that's jacqulyn Coley uh next to her is
uh a star in her own right uh her movie
comes out has been out now on on video
on demand for a little bit now after a
great theatrical run and doing a lot of
the festivals all that circuit always
low as the movie She's the co-founder of
the World Girls Empire she's one of my
dear friends Roxy strier is here yeah
and uh this is just so exciting that we
get to talk about a movie that really is
just a bunch of fluff and and cake and
and nothing too deep so now we get to
know each other a little bit more mhm my
first time seeing this movie I did it
just for the show just for for you guys
you're welcome this was your first time
seeing New Year's Eve the 2011 classic
the classic it was my first time and I
will say it shocked
me it truly shocked me it was a wild
experience it was a surprising film for
Roxy we're going to get into our
thoughts about that now again this is
part of the I guess you could say
Trilogy of Gary Marshall holiday movies
that you know Gary Marshall the
legendary director who you know the tail
end of his career is just I like working
with with these people and we don't need
a big premise we're just going to make a
lot of story lines out of this whether
it's on Valentine's Day which was the
first one and then we got New Year's Eve
and then a few years later we got
Mother's Day and so we have this Trilogy
of movies that are just it's kind of
like Love Actually where it's just a
bunch of story lines all going zigging
and zagging all over the place and where
did it land 7% rotten yeah 7% on the
Tomato Meter now again for those of you
listening to maybe this show or watch us
for the first time welcome the Tomato
Meter goes up to 100 so seven out of a
100 not the best and did do better with
the audience it's 45% which is still
rotten there's no freshness anywhere for
any of these movies on the Tomato Meter
or the audience score the highest that
we get is 47% for the audience score of
Valentine's Day so Roxy let me ask you
because I know Jacqueline has either by
her own free will or her job has had to
see all three of these movies have you
seen any of these did you see
Valentine's Day or Mother's Day no which
is kind of bizarre for me because I tend
to like for lack of better words trash
and that's what I had heard was going on
with this Trilogy and this Trilogy you
know there's Star Wars all the great you
know there's Back to the Future and then
there's the holidays amazing trilogy but
I love love actually and that's what
when you think about the posters for
these movies if you were ever sitting at
a bus stop you would look up and just
see the star studded past of these and
it is enticing because you look and
you're like those are 17 of my favorite
actors of all time all in the same movie
I think that I just never ended up
seeing them because probably of the
Tomato Meter is this the lowest ranking
movie you guys have ever done on the
show no we've done like a zero haven't
we there's a zero we might have done a
couple zeros but I it's been a while
it's getting down to
7% is impressive like that's actually a
feat of strength in in some weird
through the Looking Glass kind of way
it's it's very especially when you talk
about the star power involved with this
movie like I'm just going to read some
names for you kids okay uh let's start
with hoe Berry Jessica Beal Abigail
bresin ludicrous Matthew brck Robert
dairo Josh Dell Hector elando K always
Carl Gino kathern hgle Aston ker goes on
and on and on and it lands with of
course John Bon jovies in it so that's
why when back when when Christian harof
and I were doing schmo's no we saw this
movie cuz we were going to review it and
also it had jbj in it and and I support
any film Endeavor John bonjovi does
whether it's vampires or whether it's
the classic and I mean that actual
classic Young Guns too yeah I mean Young
Guns Too obviously how many Oscar
winners we have on here we have hiy we
have I think there's four Oscar there
four Oscar winners on here yeah because
we have we have hie we have Hillary
Swank winners yes I'm like Hillary Swank
Michelle fiper ever win anything she was
nominated for an oscar but I don't
believe she's won and Robert dairo has
won one you're forgetting a Musical one
two musical ones actually what because
common won an Oscar and John bonjovi was
nominated for an Oscar that's
correct yeah what's that John Lithgow
never won anything no I mean a lot of
these people should have abigo bresin
was nominated John ligal should have
been nominated for best supporting actor
in Orange County you haven't seen that
movie Brian put it on the list for next
year producer Brian's going to put
Orange County the comedy it's it's
really funny um this movie is like a
comedy It's a drama it's got a little
bit of everything and so you know I sit
down to watch this and I'm kind of like
ready to get wrapped up in one of the
story lines if not multiple because I
forgot a lot of the goings on all I knew
is that it took place primarily in Times
Square on New Year's Eve we go so many
different places from there which
will'll get into with movie talk but let
me start with our esteemed guest Roxy
strier uh 7% on the Tomato Meter is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong you know I've
probably been a guest on this show with
you two 20 times and and this is you're
a fan favorite this is the first time
that I had to send Mark a text message
that said holy guacamole like what did
you guys just have me watch that being
said you cleaned up your language for
the show yeah no I text him guacamole
and he was like G williker for sure but
you know okay I personally think that
anything that is well lit that you can
hear should be at least a 20% % because
this there was the amount of extras in
this movie alone each deserve a one one
millionth of a percentage which would
put us up to 20% making movies is hard
it's very difficult but that being said
because we know how the tomato tomato
meter works and we know that that means
that 7% of the people actually liked
this movie it's kind of a I mean
astounding that it has that high of a
percentage but I think this is a little
too low only because I had such a good
time with it okay okay I I will say look
a couple times my heartstrings my cold
dead heart may have been tugged at it
may have like my heart wasn't my cold
dead heart wasn't awoken by this movie
but occasionally it snored and it like
kind of shived like it had a dream so
it's not snor okay look I was having a
conversation tear jerker a little bit
you and Jack when you and I were talking
about how good it feels to have a good
cry and I pointed out that I haven't had
a good cry in like 5 years and I and I
don't I can help with that I'm sure you
I need somebody in my life that's gonna
help like I need just a good and this
got me close a couple times but I don't
think it's the movie I think it's just
because I haven't actually cried in so
long that I see Robert dairo in like a
hospital bed and I'm just like it's just
a you know there's so much water backed
up in my eyes that something's got to
come out do you feel because I feel like
Ryan Tomatoes is pretty dead on with 7%
I feel bad saying it no it's right it's
absolutely right also as as a person
that saw this movie like we just
recently did son-in-law where we were
talking about like your run of paully
shore movies I had a run of Gary
Marshall movies which are movies that
don't ask much of you but they're really
fun they're familyfriendly I you know
what I mean these are blue sky type
Cinema and I do enjoy Blue Sky Cinema
because the world is dark and I watch
dark movies all the time this was the
movie that made me be like you know what
Gary Let It Go Let It Go just I think at
this point in his career with Gary
Marshall it's like I I I appreciate that
he's making movies like this
you know at that stage where I don't
necessarily want to see like Labor Day
directed by David Fincher like I don't
need that kind of movie sometimes we
just want to put on stuff that look
there's a reason why cotton candy is
very popular at the State Fair yeah it's
just nice and fluffy and it's fun to put
in our mouths and we do feel a little
sick afterwards but we knew that was
going to happen going into it and and we
knew this was going to happen not this
bad but there is something impressive
about the fact that it did cause each of
us to have an extreme reac
like it was not a boring movie you
didn't watch this and think like ah
snoozefest despite the fact that your uh
your heart apparently was snoring I
don't think you were snoring you know
that there was my jaw was actually on
the ground for some of this I had my
little sister watched this with me and
she was like why would you ever do that
to me halfway through she said this is
horrible but by the end I looked over I
swear to you she was crying she was
crying and I honestly felt it too
because you for some reason you're
invested in these characters probably
because you know the actors and probably
because you love the actors like you
with the Robert dairo one it is sad to
see him in a hospital bed that's Robert
dairo it's Robert dairo that's the
problem with this movie is the movie
rests so much of what works on it on the
Charisma of its leads and the fact that
it was a Tik Tok movie before Tik Tok
because we're just cutting from scene to
scene and so it's sort of like episodic
in the sense that you're like well I
need to know what happened with this one
and you know they're all connected so
you're just waiting till the moment that
you figure out that this person knows
that person and this person used to bang
that person like you're just waiting for
it that sounds like a very good critical
review on the negative side of this
movie and so that's what we're going to
transition into now I'm not going to put
the onus on jacn or Roxy to actually
give us a synopsis can can you guys
think of a story line that you want to
give a synopsis for Robert janiro nearly
dies okay uh Katherine Hegel is
insufferable starting the trend of her
doing that in film and Hal Berry
literally plays a nurse which I was like
you're going to get Halle Berry like
that nurse gets wied up in year one
there's not a doctor that lets that
nurse just be a nurse that's very fair
Sarah Jessica Parker is
Cinderella and her daughter is learning
the tragedy that is teenage Hood oh yeah
very good story lines I will simply say
on top of that that Hillary Swank has a
ball to drop and we're not sure if it's
gonna happen and ludicrous is clearly
supposed to be her lover why are we
playing like that bothered me I forgot
what was Seth Meyers was in it but he
didn't have a romantic he's having a
baby he's out the pregnancy that's what
it was then he gives away
$25,000 because he felt bad he won that
fairen square that was ridiculous that
was before he got the the late night
hosting gig so not sure they had a lot
of funds to spare there trying to pay
the bills we are going to turn it over
to our buddy who pays the bills by being
our expert review curation manager here
at Rotten Tomatoes he is Tim Ryan and
this is a segment where Tim's going to
tell us what the critics were saying at
the time of the release of New Year's
Eve given that Tomato Meter I have a
feeling I know which way this is going
two minutes with Tim two minutes with
Tim over his long and distinguished
career director Gary Marshall wasn't
necessarily a critical darling but
movies like beaches Pretty Woman and the
princess diaries remain popular
favorites to millions of people but give
him a secular holiday a bunch of movie
stars a whole lot of clich shadeed in a
big dollish maltz and critics are in a
less than celebratory Mood New Year's
Eve which we are discussing today is
rotten at 7% on the Tomato Meter with
142 reviews and it has a 45% audience
score and just for comparison
Valentine's Day from 2010 is rotten at
18% and Mother's Day from 2016 is rotten
at 8% so what did the critics have to
say in a rotten review Lisa Kennedy of
the Denver Post wrote the only thing
that can Inspire more cynicism than a
holiday's coerced emotions may be a film
that both exploits and celebrates set
emotions however in a fresh review Owen
gber of Entertainment Weekly called it a
movie I often found myself laughing at
in ridicule and one that also gave me a
lump in the throat so I guess you could
say I had a good time the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads shallow
sappy and dull New Year's Eve assembles
a star studded cast for no discernable
purpose so that's New Year's Eve and I
want our listeners to know that if the
movies have any predictive Powers then
we can expect 2024 to be just like a boy
and his dog the 13th floor and
Highlander to the quickening that was
great I like the predictive future of of
the 202 24s that we've already witnessed
what I like more and I think it tickled
Roxy's funny bone as well is Tim's line
a dollop of Schmaltz it's more than a
dollop like you're at a confection store
you're getting your ice cream and it's
just oh we need like Ault like I feel
like that's something wiie woner and OAA
would for us and that's the right word
for it sappy y sappy yep nothing wrong
with some sap I'll take the tree and
I'll tap it give me all the sap hey I
don't I and by the way I'm the intended
audience for this movie you know what I
mean like this was you read a lot of
those I dare I say a dollop of of
Schmaltz and a heap and helpen of schut
cidi yeah with those romance BS you smut
and schaltz are like I'm with it I'm so
with it but this one I need more and
unfortunately I do feel this was the
cast where the names got too unwieldy
like the amount of names got too un I
was going to I I have a point to make on
that and that's why we have movie talk
that's why we have a whole section
dedicated to you know actually talking
about the movie something that producer
Brian cleverly titled movie
[Music]
talk not to take Brian's shine away but
that's actually producy Lucy came up
with movie talk soy Lucy y she's doing
great we love our some Lucy we love our
some Brian uh not so much New Year's Eve
but but the thing like okay this was
your first time seeing it yes okay um
cuz I saw it in the theater jacine did
you have to see this did you see it in
the theater cuz you thought it might be
in your wheelhouse no no I did not see
this one in the theater because this one
was definitely early Rotten Tomatoes
days and how bad it was definitely
scared me away from it in the theater
but I definitely watched it immediately
when it came home and it was like no
also 2011 was a weird time for me it's
one of you ever have those those years
where you're just like I know I didn't
watch movies at this time what's going
on let's get into it I'm not going to
talk about that
boy we're not going to talk about that
boy I just wanted to hear the sentence
end with boy that's all not going to
talk about that boy but there was there
was moments I do go through periods in
my existence and my career where like I
really want to go see a movie every week
and then there's other times when like
even during and it kind of was nice that
it coincided with the the actors and
writers and us being on strike but it's
like I didn't feel like I saw barbie and
I saw arheimer and then I was like I'm
going to go get invested in movies again
once the strikes are over and once
always Lola comes out on B so those were
my two kind of benchmarks but back in
this time in 2011 Roxy I was seeing
movies three four five times a week
partially because ofo and partially just
because I just loved going to the movies
and eating popcorn and so this one I
wasn't dreading it you know it had
enough that's the thing about these
movies they have so many stars in them
that you're bound to hit three or four
that you really like as a viewer so was
there any optimism going into this
viewing experience for you was it based
on somebody in the movie or just based
on the premise I mean of course I I
tried to be optimistic going in but it
has been over a decade since this movie
came out and I have not heard one
positive thing from anybody maybe that's
why I actually didn't despise my time
watching it because I thought it was
going to be boring lame and instead
while we spent no more than five minutes
with any character there was no
development done at all the story lines
were absolutely egregious and I spent
the entire time just trying to guess who
ultimately was going to end up hooking
up in the end uh only to be completely
shocked when Michelle feifer gets dipped
by uh frat boy zon that was so rude to
Zack afron I'm so sorry that I just BL I
forgot about Zack Efron cuz he's such a
little cutie I can't even help myself in
this I was like if I'm a shell Fifer I'm
fluttering I'm I'm flying I'm fluttering
that's Michelle fer 100% you're right
Michelle Fifer is maybe the most
beautiful woman that's ever lived so
both of them although they had no
chemistry and what was that kiss bizarre
uh but anyway as I'm watching it I'm
invested in all of this so going into it
I didn't have much hope and it actually
passed my expectations of that
7% was there a character that stood out
to me the only one that I really feel
like really touched me me was Lil Miss
Sunshine Abigail Bren yep yeah because
relatable I mean you when we see her
finally she's defied her mother she's
gotten on the train she goes to Time
Square everybody's having easy time now
getting time Mom in the face in the face
didn't pick up her call she said no she
gets there and she sees the guy she
likes making out with another girl
brutal I mean been there devastating and
I honestly that moment was like okay I
get what this movie was going for
there's a little storyline for each
person that you're supposed to relate to
and that was my one I related to the
teen story see okay you had an issue
with uh a couple of these no I just have
a question where was this in Zach
Efron's High School Musical filmography
this was post High School Musical okay
but the trilogy or like so he's growing
out he's growing out of the High School
Musical thing and he took some roles
there was like that DJ movie he did that
was just kind of ridic ridiculous like
we are your friends or something like
that but before that he did 17 that's
where I want to know is where was this
with 17 again because it was I think it
was just after 17 if I'm not mistaken
but but I I actually I I thought Zack
Efron was one of the highlights of this
movie that's what I was going to say he
wasn't the guy I was going in to the
movie rooting for but I just to see him
kind of get out of the high school thing
just a little bit and be somebody who's
now it felt like this was this guy's
first time on his own in in his life in
the the character's life and so he was
making some decisions that maybe he
wouldn't have made 6 months a year two
years ago back when he was in high
school and and so that was kind of cool
and I love Michelle fight for being
happy yeah but the most egregious moment
of the entire movie had to do with him I
couldn't believe that this was something
that actually took place he's on the
phone with his homie probably Ashton
Kutcher right and we haven't even talked
about Liam Michelle on this movie the
elevator stuff he's on the phone with
Ashton Kutcher and next to him is
Michelle Fifer I mean they are like a
stone throw away they are the distance
between us right now and he's on the
phone and he's like yeah this girl is
totally whack you know and then she
hears it and he's shocked I mean she is
literally an arms length away from him
and he was like a I didn't know you
heard that she's in the same room she's
right there what kind of a that was the
most bizarre Direction Choice I've ever
seen just have have him not know she's
there he knew she was there he took her
there he's looking at her he says it and
then he's like how' you hear that I was
like you got to be kidding me what just
happened there I give him credit because
it was 2011 and uh you know back then we
were still screaming into our indor
phones like we were just we didn't have
all the buds and all that stuff so we
were we were talking we were loud
talkers back in the day wasn't
Whispering she would have heard if he
was whispering she was right there I
agree he dropped the ball but that was
also back when like that was like not a
rarity but enough of a rarity back in
2007 was when we got the iPhone right
that was enough of a rarity at that that
time and this was 2011 so you should
know like I think we dit the
blackberries by then but that was one of
the more memorable story lines I would
say is is the Zach Efron Michelle feifer
Dynamic and the thing that ended up
bothering me about this movie the most
ironically Jack when you touched on it
is that there's too many storylines
there's too many things it's almost like
it's like a spoiled kid at Christmas you
you come downstairs and you're looking
at and there's just too many presents
like you're not you're never going to
feel attachment to any of these presents
cuz there's so much crap there's so many
I don't need this many famous people I
think that's the genius of a movie like
Love Actually which I've made fun of and
criticize certain storylines because
they're very ridiculous but I think Love
Actually has just the right amount of
different things going on to connect
it's perfect whereas this it's just it's
like trying to one up Love Actually with
more story lines and more stars and it
got to be the point where I can't it
might have been Willam Michelle and it
just might have been the time of the
movie but but I could not stomach one
more famous person coming in here and
having yet another story line that I had
to keep track of my brain and then I
think it was her showing up in the
elevator I'm like this is too many
a-listers God damn it so this is the
thing that I can appreciate now watching
this movie is I know how this movie gets
made the way that it gets made is these
are all New York actors and when they
said hey we're going to film this in New
York you can go home to your kids every
night it's going to be like Valentine's
Day so you're going to be a part of a
movie with other likable people look we
got Hal Bailey already on it we got
Robert dairo already on it we got these
other people on it then they all join
they're not say no to Gary Marshall you
know what I well it's not just Gary
Marshall it's the other people that sign
on I guarantee you the first person he
gets to say yes is Robert DeNiro maybe
shortly after that he gets Michelle
feifer maybe Hillary SW gets your Oscar
contenders which by the way producer
Brian did tell me John lith gu was
nominated for two okay cuz you both
rolled your eyes at me and I feel like I
I said he should have been nominated for
Orange County sadly he was not it was
Terms of Endearment and the world
according to GARP that world according
to Gar so he had a good run there that
is a good run there and he's still going
but that's my whole point is that the
the idea that like once you get those
people to sign on other people are
willing to sign on to it it did get a
bit unwieldy I went and checked uh
Valentine's Day has about half of this
cast and they're all intertwined and the
other thing I will say about the
Valentine's Day cast just comparing it
to this one these are all great people
not necessarily the personalities that
you're thinking of when you're thinking
people like Jamie Fox people like
Jennifer Garner people like Topher Grace
people like Ann hathway you know what I
mean like these were names at the time
that not were just popular people loved
them people obsessed about them and
people had that sort of like internet
boy friend energy these are all more
established people that we like but I
love Carla Gino I don't know if I'm like
rushing to see every movie that she's in
but you tell me that there's a movie
with Jamie Fox I'm going to go see it
yeah I kind of feel you on that and
absolutely understand how it was made I
mean I would have cut off my armed to be
in a movie with any of these individuals
like so I why wouldn't you sign on to it
and it's not like being in this movie
demoed their careers it's not like after
this Robert dairo was having a hard time
getting work and he just didn't know
what to do but I actually going back to
what you were talking about Mark where
there's so many names on here that
wasn't the most egregious thing to me
the most egregious part to me was what
they did with those people like for
example the I'm sorry I know we love
John bonjovi here and I I don't want to
say anything his performance was really
fine he did a totally fine job with it
his performance was really fine yeah no
you know he did actually decent actor so
I he he was better in U 571 yes right
but he's F he's totally he did a fine
job but kathern higel the the whole
premise of their storyline is that he
treats her like crapola he leaves her
after proposing to her and then he gets
her this job that he doesn't tell her
that he gets she thinks she's done it on
her own Merit and she didn't and then he
says I'll be with you forever and we
were supposed to be like it's on like
Donkey Kong yeah we're in on this that
it was every storyline was like that
like I'm not rooting for you guys to be
together so that's an issue same thing
with Michelle feifer and Zack Efron Zack
Efron was a a complete deag the entire
time to her behind her back and then at
the end kisses her and is like now it's
all better right and she's like Yay I
got all my accomplishments like every
single single story even the Sarah
Jessica Parker story line where it's
like okay so you didn't want your kid
going out but now you were like actually
it's getting close to midnight so I
should go meet up with that man that I
gave my number to a year ago and just
let my kid gallivant around as a
teenager after midnight even though I
didn't want her out before midnight and
then she's there and it's like oh but
we're happy cuz she changed out of the
clogs like what are we talking about it
wasn't the who was in it it was the the
storylines that they asked us to root
for were unrootable in rotable
absolutely not rootable there was no
rooting for any of the things that were
going on I was like give me something
give me somebody that I want this love
story that I want them to get together
that I want them to succeed in whatever
way and for an entire movie to be called
New Year's Eve and us to not deal with
resolutions at all like what about
talking about being a better person are
any of you guys going to talk about what
you want to do next year instead you
guys had a bucket list for this year
that's not what New Year's Eve is that
that was just a delightful I see this
upset you well you just carve out that
minute and a half and that's pretty much
what the the the you know the premise of
this show was this is that's the promise
that the show just lived up to thank you
for giving me that time that moment that
Soap Box because I really genuinely had
feelings on this so I mean again I'm
looking at at this and I'm trying to
think B to your point um who was I
actually rooting for were there people I
actually cared about other than the fact
that I like them as f famous people
obviously I'm rooting for John bonjovi
to do whatever he wants to do with his
life okay if he wants to go on tour and
keep being a rockstar go ahead and do it
if he wants to cancel the tour so he can
be with kathern Hegel knock yourself out
dude I want you to be happy I was
actually rooting for Hector Al's
character Kaminski because he's sort of
the I mean look he's what it all comes
down to on New Year's Eve because
there's a mechanical malfunction with
the ball as all the high school boys
Snicker including myself and we can't
get the ball to go up can't get the ball
to drop so and this is kind of Hillary
Swank like her whole job her whole
career has been building up to this
moment so you really got to stick the
landing so we call this one guy Kaminsky
elando who gets in there and he's the
only electrician in the whole city who's
going to know how to figure
out he's going to find the one light he
gets in there and you think it's going
to be like this intense Lethal Weapon 3
opening get cut the right wire see and
he just kind of goes in there and fixes
it and it's pretty much pie gake and we
don't really sweat it after that um the
I I can't really think of any other
storyline I meano DeNiro dairo is the
only one but okay I cared about him and
I teared up about him because he's
basically this old man who I'm sorry
Roxy he may not have to make any
resolutions let's put it that way and it
turns out that he is the father of
Hillary Swank's character and he's been
a pretty crummy dad so that's why I
didn't care about him as much as the
movie went on is because he was not the
best dad up to that point oh and that's
like a that's a mortal sin for you that
is a mortal sin for Mar Ellis you don't
want to be a dad but bad dads are the
ones that you will crucify over anybody
don't think that you get if your
daughter wants to come and watch the
ball drop with you on your deathbed fine
but it's like you don't deserve that
100% I was not rooting for him we hear
him sit down with Hal Barry who for some
reason he thinks is his see this is what
I say y'all didn't tell me why I was
rooting for him I was rooting for him
because of Hal Bailey because of H Barry
because if you know anything about
Robert dairo I think the reason why
Robert dairo signed up for this movie is
Gary Marshall said you will get to act
next to H Berry and if you don't know
Robert Deniro's dating history I think
that's the reason why he signed up so
that was the reason why I was rooting
for for for him not him the character
root for Robert dairo like I'm not
rooting for his character I'm rooting
for Robert dairo getting to flirt on
screen with Hal Berry for the entire
runtime of this movie that is what I was
I think that's completely fair and you
know what as we were watching it I was
thinking to myself you know how
sometimes you'll play that game that's
like six degrees of separation and
you're trying to connect two different
actors and I was thinking I'm going to
remember this moment that Robert dairo
and hie Barry are in this death scene on
his deathbed right now because this will
help connect all the actors that have
ever been I am not above saying that I
think that Gary Marshall might have had
a bad experience in the mid-2000s
playing the popular game six degrees to
Kevin Bacon I think he probably maybe he
lost the Penny Marshall and he was mad
about it so he said God damn it I'm
going to make not just one I'm going to
make a Trilogy of movies that have
literally every famous person in them
ever so I never have to lose six degrees
of Kevin Bacon again cuz you're finding
all the degrees in this movie I mean I
forgot about some other people in this
am uh Amari stmy is in this one that's
the other thing that that is in this one
but yeah no the H he was playing for the
Knicks at the time he playing that's
what I'm saying they just got people in
New York other thing about this movie
you could just tell how it was a
Frankenstein shoot like you can tell hiy
and Robert Jiro were together but so
many people in this movie they were
never near each other all the phone
calls like it's just these people never
spoke to each other they didn't even
know each other they probably didn't
even meet each other at the premiere I
feel like there's more stunt casting in
this one because in Valentine's Day
these stunt cast was at the time Taylor
Swift it was like oh Taylor Swift is
like her first I think it was her first
theatrical her first big theatrical
movie and it was her it was the Taylor
tlor and this one it even though it's
more established actors it just it felt
like who's in New York that can say yes
everybody is there and I think the
promise that Gary made them all when
they were cast is you do not have to
study your lines at all you can
literally look at this the day of make
it up and that's how you separate you
know John bonjovi he can be a pretty
good actor versus the Robert dairo who
can do an Oscar caliber role in his
sleep oh and they wanted to make sure we
got Matthew brck and Sarah Jessica
Parker to do their first movie together
since maybe the 80s I don't know that
they didn't they do a movie together in
the 80s they might have done it in the
movie in the 80s but it was kind of fun
seeing Matthew br's character show up
knowing that Sarah jesica Parker's in
the mie and they're married yeah I mean
I just figured that that was like a part
of the I'm I'm thinking of the pitches
for this because this is the movie that
happened that eventually led to the
remember the movie 43 remember that
movie movie 43 yeah uh it was this team
up comedy movie that literally got
everyone from Like Richard Gear to Chris
Pratt what year are we talking uh around
this time 2012 2013 it was basically a
bunch of short vignettes that were all
meant to be iic so this men being the c
word the movie 43 was trying to be
runchy and like and just like like kind
of gross out it was never about finding
the heart or finding the good in things
or like having these these all these
tentacles kind of wrap up cutely it was
just about here's a d and they had
nothing to do with each other so it was
like here's 10 minutes of Hugh Jackman
and he's got balls on his chin here's 10
minutes of Richard Gear doing whatever
here's 10 so that it's it's I think that
might be 0% but these movies killed that
this was like back when these producers
could tell these lies to get these
people to sign up for be like it's just
two days come in do your thing but that
this is part of it how easy can you make
it for the stars shoot it in New York
and then also who else is in it that
where if this is embarrassing they'll be
embarrassed too I need another moment
from you guys if if you will uh get back
on that Soap Box I got to talk to you
guys about leam Michelle in this movie I
I just want to go down this path for a
second she's stuck in an elevator with
Ashton Kutcher and that's how for about
half the movie Yes but she is a backup
singer to John Bon Jovi and what happens
to leam Michelle in this movie is that
she drops a bracelet in the elevator
that we never reference that has no
relevance to absolutely anything she
then is out of the elevator and is able
to somehow make it to Times Square in
time for what she needed to do the
backup singing okay meanwhile Ashton
Kutcher who's been stuck on an elevator
for hours gets right back on the
elevator that he was just stuck on with
50 more people absolutely ridiculous
okay but let's follow Li Michelle still
so then leam Michelle does get there and
she's like H but it's just such a bummer
because I want to be the star of the
show somehow ashon Kutcher gets through
John Bon Joy's security and gets there
and is able to kiss her because he's the
drummer he makes up that he's the Dr
nobody ID him he goes through all the
Time Square okay great still with you
guys he gives her this bracelet and he's
like cuz I know that this could mean
something
balance all right ridiculous premise
fine still with you guys she gets on
stage and she's backup singing the thing
that she's there to do okay still with
you guys John B Joy leaves the show he
leaves the show and somehow what they
say is you know your new backup singer
actually she's going to perform on New
Year's Eve everybody who came here to
see you no it's fine just leave in the
middle of your show to go make out with
a girl that you left because after you
proposed to her you were too much of a
dag to actually stay with her so then
somehow Rachel Barry Liam Michelle gets
on stage and sings She's the singer of
the show at midnight at midnight a
asinine asinine like you guys had me you
had me you had me she's the star of the
show she got and she's like and I did it
who everybody would thrown Tomatoes
Rotten Tomatoes get off the stage who
are you you backup singer I've been
standing out in the cold in the seven
degree temperature the same as the
Rotten Tomato score of this movie for 15
hours like just and everybody's like Yay
they were a very supportive New York
crowd you don't know New Yorkers if you
think that that was even close to how
they would have reacted to this
no-name balance bracelet girl just that
was ridiculous I mean you can go you
don't have to go any further than ask
Amari stmi or how New York fans feel
when they feel like they're not getting
the product that they expected that they
paid for broken on the stage and the
ball is broken and the ball's broken uh
the one thing I do know from this movie
and I do remember it was partially paid
by the New York tourism board oh okay
that is an aspect of this movie that's
interesting and I think it's well done
and and I'm sure there's a bunch of
footage that they actually shot on New
Year's they might even film some scenes
the day of leading up to New Year they
probably yeah filmed it captured it or
whatever or like took it from like
Dick's Rocking Eve like like captured
b-roll from that and then put it in
there but yeah this was partially paid
by the New York tourism board because
this is this is not like post 911 that
was 2011 but it was still in that like
New York wasn't coming back from the
financial crisis 10 year anniversary
housing crisis just happened we had no
such thing as as Co or anything like
that yet so the question is does a movie
like this make you feel like you want to
go to New York to see the ball drop in
Time Square more no or less it was never
really a thing that I ever wanted to do
and I feel like as I become more kogin
with every passing month and year that I
like to do less things and I don't think
that New York when watching the ball
drop is going to be one of them because
I'm watching this movie and I just see
all these story lines and I don't really
see myself in any of these story lines
so I'm like I don't think that I need to
be a guy who watches the ball drop I
hate this about myself but this made me
want to go more because what I know as
somebody who grew up in Boston which is
three and a half hours away from New
York City what I know is that I have
plenty of friends who have gone there
that wear diapers ERS because you cannot
leave to go pee that it is below
freezing they are shaking crying they're
so cold I know the reality of waiting
there is miserable but watching this
they were all so happy they were all
like you know what that was a beautiful
speech Hillary Swank thank you for
telling us that this is the reason the
ball is broken is so that we can all
reflect on our lives and take this pause
and I was like that is really really
beautiful this is May this is
romanticized New Year's Eve New York
City in a way that is not real and if
this was the experience then I would go
if it it looked like it was about 40°
all right great I can stand 40° I can
stand there and and just lovey doy with
my friend so yeah I it made me want to
go more I don't think it's real it's not
okay so it's not real but you want to go
to that idealized do not give me that
look right now have you been to Time
Square for New Year's Eve no first of
all Time Square is Amateur hour like it
is amateur hours they have an Olive
Garden anybody out yes they have an
Olive Garden they don't even have a tji
Fridays anymore close oh rip I used to
eat there yeah yeah close no it is
Amateur hour the only version of New
York Times Square that I could do is the
bougie version where you get somebody's
hotel room or park or or apartment that
overlooks the ball that you could be at
their bougie little party to overlook
the ball drop and wave to The Peasants
and like not be anywhere near like still
be inside a domicile that is not related
to that insanity how's our budget
looking for next year because I feel
like we close out we'll talk about
either Mother's Day or Valentine's Day
we'll have Roxy on us the guest we the
four of us will all go in not on any of
our dimes on like a nice you know get
get some high-rise hotel that overlooks
the ball that's the way to do New York
because you know what you can do in your
hotel room or what I could do in the
comfort of my own home that I can't do
it at Time Square is I can just walk to
the fridge and get a beer yeah and I
don't know what the concession situation
is like that's what it all boils down to
I'm happy wearing the the diaper
okay no you're not I'm happy wearing a
diaper not after you use it I'm going to
I'm going to be of some liquid courage
up by then I need to know where I can
get hot dogs I need to know where I can
get like a beer or soda they do have
vendors down there but it's like going
to like Woodstock 99 it's like $200 for
you know to eat the food look the Macy's
day parade that sort of thing like the
Outdoor Adventures like I'm not about it
also I will say this there are a ton of
amazing New Year New Year's Eve movies
that just Pummel this one including one
of my all-time favorites the apartment
there's also cigarettes there's just so
many other different ways to do New
Year's Eve SLE Seattle Sleepless in
Seattle but they're not called New
Year's Eve so when you type it in it
might not necessarily show up this is
for lazy people and and like as a person
who is actually a fan of not New Year's
Eve as most people celebrate it but New
Year's Eve the way I celebrate it at
home with friends like doing it my own
sort of way any movie that doesn't talk
about how awful this holiday is really
deeply does not really should not be
called it and there's like people that
are explain yourself like this movie you
hate New Year's Eve it's Amateur hour it
is Amateur hour it is not a night for
people that are good with drinking
driving or socializing it is a night for
amateurs who only who need designated
holidays to tell them when to do things
I'm not saying that like Baby I'm an
amateur then I love me some New Year's
Eve and you're not the only one in fact
our what is it about New Year's Eve that
that you because we've heard
Jacqueline's um sort of reasons for
keeping it on the Shelf as far as your
favorite holidays go what is it about
New Year's Eve that inspires Roxy why do
you get up for this night is it is it
the the the promise of the future that
we didn't really get to talk about much
in this movie yeah I don't think it's
for amateurs although respect everything
that you believe I mean no no I
shouldn't say everyone who goes out on
New Year's Eve is an amateur but there's
a lot of amateurs out on New Year's Eve
I definitely hear you and you know
there's always going to be like that
frat star mentality of the person who's
trying to kiss somebody at midnight
because they think that that will
somehow be I don't know big points for
them browny points but for me as
somebody who is single and lives alone I
love any excuse to celebrate and this
one especially focuses on being a better
version of yourself or at least that's
what it's supposed to focus on now do I
think that our society is hysterical
that what you do the day before you're
about to start your resolutions is get
out and get and get absolutely plastered
like the the ritual is I'm going to get
as drunk as I can so tomorrow I wake up
with a over to be the best version of me
that I could ever be that it's
ridiculous what we do but at the same
time I love resolutions I'm a big goal
oriented person I love my birthday for
that reason I love this holiday for that
reason anything that's kind of a reset
and going into a new year does bring
promise especially if you've had a crap
previous year whether it's a mental
shift or what I think that it also it
has no uh religious affiliations which
for me coming after Christmas is usually
like get me out of here get me out of
here sorry not that I I'm so happy
anybody who loves Christmas but it's
just like you know it's as a Jewish
person you're like I'm inundated with
this yeah well we don't live in a
Christian Nation and yet everything's
shut down so I'm like I just wanted to
go to CVS and get some nail polish like
can be open but anyway you know New
Years everybody can celebrate it it's
for it's a nonsecular kind of like
holiday where I I do appreciate the
resolution aspect of New Year's now we
can all agree New Year's Day should be
January 2nd because what I do on New
Year's Eve is regardless of whether I
had an early night or a late night which
I've done plenty of both in my career uh
then you wake up the next day you order
pizza you watch nothing but college
football bowl games all day and then you
figure out what your next year is going
to be like before we get out of here
though we talked about the movie Enough
we probably talked about the movie more
than anybody else has ever talked about
the movie in a positive way including
the folks making it while they were
making it um New Year's memories do we
have like highlights low lights what's
been like a a beautiful a crazy a Nutty
a Nutty New Year New Year's Eve I kissed
I My First Kiss was on a New Year's Eve
okay in high school kiss wait first kiss
ever yeah wow and it didn't take place
till like 400 a. like I had to work man
um so what happens after midnight in
your soul are you thinking I blew it no
no we we weren necessarily like like
meant to be together it wasn't like I'm
going to this party for this girl so I
can kiss her at midnight it was just
like everybody's hanging out having a
good time and then we all finally pair
off time to sleep in a bed and it's like
well I guess I I I I drew I drew you
and uh we're just like we were friends
we were just talking and like you know a
kiss happened it you know good it was a
good initiation to you know being an
adult in a relationship um but I also
have gotten to ring in the near Year on
stage a bunch and like at The Comedy
Store I was there you know um last week
and that's that's always fun you know
whether it's amateurs or whether it's
professional New Year's Eve partyers in
the crowd it's always always always a
fun time uh Jackal I think my favorite
uh New Year's Eve was the year that I
spent in Thailand on my and I think that
I knew you when I was on those trips it
was my single solo travel Girl
Adventures and I still like I love being
in a couple um with that man that lives
in my house but I will say like going to
Southeast Asia and like really like
really traveling over there and like
spending New Year's Eve like it was like
it was literally like we took um what do
you call like those Rick Shaws out to
the middle of nowhere and like I was
just a bunch of partyers it felt very
leader out DiCaprio in the beach was it
like their version of Burning Man
something like that no it was just
really just like a bunch of like you
know people celebrating for the holiday
and we all sort of made like a beach New
Year's Eve party basically you know what
I mean like it was very DIY and having
that sort of Adventure other thing I
love about New Year's Eve and I will a
testament to this for sure New Year's
Eve has the better music because then
you have what are you doing New Year's
New Year's Eve um that song and old
Langs like I feel like 1999 yeah like I
feel like the New Year's Eve movie The
New Year's Eve music of the holiday
music is the best music also secular
always fun I just I love New Year's Eve
movies you to New Year's Day you kind of
squeeze in I love New Year's day as well
and then I like uh several movies I like
to watch uh on New Year's Day and also
that is when in Britain They Call It
Boxing Day the day after New Year's uh
is boxing day and they do lots of sales
and lots of television shows that are
just built for boxing day that sort of
like wrap up the year so I love year and
review type stuff that's why we have
college football bowl games it's it's
their season in review yeah I appreciate
you coming to me last because I had so
much time to think about it and I am
coming up completely blank regardless
because I love Yeah that's the thing
it's like do I remember all my new great
time no I I have been I've spent New
Year's Eve in Los Angeles and New York
and Boston uh and all of the every New
Year I've never had a bad New Year's Eve
none of them stand out I just usually
like to spend it with friends having a
few drinks making some resolutions and
calling it like it that's really what
every year looks like it doesn't really
M I've been with different people
sometimes I've had a nice little kiss
sometimes I have not uh and it it
doesn't really matter to me because it's
the start of a new year and that's kind
of why I like it not because of a one
experience that I've had you and I did
New Year's together one time you did at
um it was either the mint or the dime I
get him confused during the pandemic
when we could do standup I was doing
those virtual standup shows where I'd
have some you know some fun folks open
and then I'd do an hour of just material
that I thought was funny but there's no
crowd there and so I think producer
Brian might have been involved in a
couple of those right um doing the audio
engineering just like to and so I live
streamed it wasn't just me
performing I live streamed and like you
know you get hundreds of people watching
because that's the entertainment and so
Roxy and and Steph SRA of world girls
Fame and this show you guys came over
because you your with walking distance
of there at the so they walked over just
in time for midnight and like everybody
like had had a nice cocktail and like we
did a Q&A Roxy popped in it was F that
was really nice because we hadn't seen
each other in so long and usually it was
py yeah it was a good old Pandy good old
Pandy Pandy Express as I'm thinking
about it honestly I just really really
like this holiday I really like this
holiday but the movie not so much the
movie I don't think did the holiday
Justice it didn't have any of the things
about the holiday that I liked it it
felt very chaotic and frenzied which you
can get on New Year's sometimes but you
usually at least in this point I would
rather stay away from chaotic and
friendly and and and frenzy I like maybe
a couple Coors Lights And The Twilight
Zone cuz they they on New Year's Eve
they do a Twilight on Marathon they do
who does I think it's USA your apartment
I think it's and my apartment does so
and now and I just well I cut the chord
but and I have YouTube TV now and I
still get all the stuff as YouTube TV is
not really the chord cutting but way
they don't sponsor us but my God YouTube
TV is been Gods YouTube TV is amazing
also because unlimited downloads you can
like DVR everything they can't max out
NL Sunday Ticket which maybe not that
necessary for folks like Roxy and I this
year but I can't Mark oh my God are you
not loving the Mac Jones era sorry are
there people loving the Mac Jones era I
mean the fact that I watched a game with
my family and everybody was booing when
we actually were winning I mean there
we're we need that draft pick come on I
want y'all to get good I want y'all to
stay bad because I cannot allow the
Bears to stay bad and take that top spot
man like I cannot allow K Williams to be
in our division while Jordan love is
still it could happen um we're going to
go to outro but I want everybody to
stick around because now that roxxy's
sad and bitter about the New England
Patriots I got something that's going to
cheer up hit the
[Music]
music no mailbag this week you can email
us anytime RT is wrong rotten
tomatoes.com and let us know what movie
should we be talking about do you want
us to cover Valentine's Day do you want
Brian to spring for a nice hotel suite
New York York City December 31st so we
can do our much anticipated review of
Mother's Day and we'll watch the ball
drop as we do it um subscribe rate
review all that good stuff I know uh
last week everybody was sharing what
they listen to on Spotify and I've seen
a lot of people say that Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong is one of your favorite
podcasts you've listened to and it's one
of the most listened to I've gotten a
lot of messages like that so thank you
all for continuing to support the show
and letting us do what we love in this
cool new home that we got to welcome
Roxy into the new studio for the first
time and what a month you had to close
out 2023 I know it was a long time
coming and it was just the perfect storm
of the strikes and all this stuff but as
somebody who got to see always Lola on
the festival circuit before it was
available everywhere y'all can VOD it
now wherever you live it's got to feel
great to finally have this amazing
product out there into the world yeah I
mean honestly first of all Mark you're
just like the most supportive friend and
thank you for coming to that because it
it was where did it Premier at we we did
a film festival circuit so out here here
we did a couple of them Chinese Theater
back in Boston I got to do one Boston
film festival with a bunch of my friends
which was really cool coming through uh
but it was it's now available everywhere
and it was cool because I've been
hosting with you guys for a long time
guessing on here for Rotten Tomatoes
everybody obviously talks about like
what's the Rotten Tomatoes score and
and because I've been a part of this
place for so long to actually be
starring in a movie that then people are
checking the Rotten Tomatoes score
100% gy it was really cool it's like
this Little Indie that could and it's
been my dream forever and I just
congrats man that's something to be
really proud of there's I mean Brett
Ratner wish he could man he wishes that
he could that's amazing is it
nerve-wracking seeing the movie at a
place like Boston like where you know
you have a bunch of friends and family
coming to see it or you know the movie's
good it's not like you have to perform
that night you already know what the
movie is no it's so nerve-wracking
because when I walked in so there it was
a theater of 150 people and all of them
are people who know me and I walked in
and they all started chanting Lola Lola
and like you know the Press is there NBC
is people are there and they're seeing
all of my fratty friends out being like
Lola as I'm walking in I thought that I
was going to die of embarrassment also
was one of the greatest moments of my
life so it was really really cool but it
is nerve-wracking because you can't do
anything about it m like I shot that
movie two years ago if if yeah you know
when you're doing standup you can feel
the crowd and if they're not liking
something you can adjust you can just
shift gears you can't really do that
with a movie that's been I hope they do
otherwise you have to sit for 90 minutes
in a room with them as you feel them so
luckily people do like it I think they
understand that this is a Ultra
lowbudget Indie movie with a bunch of
people who wanted to make a really
heartfelt movie about mental health and
about a Coming of Age movie about trauma
and grief and it has a really solid
message to it the actors the the
ensemble cast myself excluded from this
are just so effing talented that it was
like just I think that people saw what
we were trying to do and they really
felt something from it felt very
breakfast Clubby like you got Andrew Guy
Candace Cruz who who were both wonderful
and talented they've been on the show as
well so it's kind of like a Ryan
Tomato's wrong releas as well and wow I
didn't even think about that yeah you
guys made the show but the story lines
that are going on in your movie are
actually like they're they're they're
good you follow them and you care about
these people New Year's Eve does feel
like that comedian who's on stage and is
trying this bit and that's not working
so let's pivot to this let's pivot to
this let's pivot pivot pivot back to
still not working let's go here Robert
diniro we're sad nothing's really
working uh there's a lot to talk about
with this movie and I think we covered
most of it and always lowly you can
check that out on v um wherever you are
you can uh check that out now finally
enjoy it and let Roxy know let us know
what you thought of the movie and um
jacine what else we got going on next
week we're kind of tbds we're keeping it
on the down low yeah we just got back so
we got a figure out exactly what we're
going to do for the year but that's why
you guys need to email us in let us know
what we haven't covered I mean we we're
going deep this year you never know we
could get deep Cuts we what a great
close of the year I mean you know New
Year's Eve is fun and we get to talk to
Roxy so we love that but like the legend
of Billy Jean was really cool son-in-law
we finally got a poly Shore movie in
here Legend So let's let's have a big
2024 folks and and whatever you're doing
whatever Walk of Life you're in whether
you watch you listen to the show thank
you and we got your back too whatever
your New Year's resolution was don't
quit the gym yet it's only been a week
you can take a rest day it's okay yeah
all right that's jacqulyn Coy that's
Roxy strier Brian Perez our Este team
producer for the whole gang here at
Rotten Tomatoes I am Mark ell is saying
well I'll say goodbye in a minute but
also Portland San Diego Boston a couple
other tour dates coming up soon thanks
for listening to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong thanks for watching us we love you
Happy New
[Music]
[Applause]
Year
[Music]
yeah